SO MUCH SEE WHEN YOU GET HERE. H
PAINT WITHOUT
MAKING A MESS AT
HOME - WE HAVE THE
>> WELCOME BACK IF YOU'RE IN
THE MOOD
TO BREAKS THROW
THINGS AND SPLASH PAY WITHOUT
MAKING A MESS AT HOME WE HAVE
THE PLACE FOR YOU ROCK IS LIVE
IN LAS VEGAS IS ADRENALINE
PLAYGROUND HAVING A SMASHING
GOOD TIME ALL A ROCKY HAHA.
>> HEY JP GOT THIS IS THE
PERFECT SEGUE BECAUSE I HEARD
YOU WERE HERE A ERFEW YEARS AGO
THIS IS THE BRAND NEW LOCATION
AT
TOWN SQUARE  JUST OPENED 2
MONTHS AGO,  BUT YOU ARE HERE A
FEW YEARS AGO AT THE OTHER
LOCATION AND YOU STARTED
SMASHING BEFORE YOU PUT AL
L
SAID IRAQ YOU DO IT BE
CAREFUL. FU
YEAH, YEAH.
>> AND WHEN THEY SAID THAT I
WAS LIKE YEAH THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY SAY HE WAS READY TO SMATOS
SOMETHING
SO NOW I'NOM RENOADY NOBUT NO
O
NOFIRSNOT ANNOD FONOREMOST, KNO
WHERE
GET THE JUMP TO HUMANS INNS
THIS.
IN THE SMASH FORT I
SHOULD LEGO FOR ABSOLUTELY SO
WE WORK WITH
THE VETERANS LIKE
COLORS TLOO MAKE SURE THEY SAT
IN A LAND FILL, THEY COME TO US
GETS MASSIVE GET RECYCLED
RIGHT AFTER ALL.
>> OKAY, SO THIS IS NOT JUST
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT JUST FOR
FUN. THIS IS YOU KNOW THIS A
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS THIS
TOO I WOULD ASSUME A 100% SO
YOU FEEL FANTASTIC AFTER YOU
GET TO LET LOOSE GET ALL THOSE
POSITIVE NEGATI
VE FEELINGS,
THE FLOW OUT AND SMASH SOME
STUFF SO A FEW WEAPONS OF
CHOICE A CHOICE AS CALL THEM
YOU GOT SHOVEL, YOU'VE GOT A
RANCH AND YOU'VE GOT ONE IN
THIS CHAIN THAT SOME ZOMBIE
INSPIRATION FOR US OVER HERE,
SO YEAH AND THOSE ON THE
APOCALYPSE ARE READY TO GO
OKAY WELL, I'M INSPIRED TO A
COACH WANT TO FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND PUT OUR
SAFETY GEAR ON ARE YOU THERE TH
AND GOAN AHEANAD ANAND ANLET AAN
MY FOR THE PRINTER OR WHATEVER
THAT IS.
>> OKAY
AND THAT WAS ONE OF
THE BIGGERBI BIBIITEMS THAT ERE
ARE SOME EASIEREA ITEMS AS WELL
SOME BOTTLES RIGH
T HERE YOU
CAN GO HAVE MASK THOSE AS
WELL.
>> BABY AND I WANT I WANT TO
LET YOU GUYS KNOW THIS IS FOR
THE ENTIRE FAMILY, BUT THE
KIDS HAVE TO BE 10 YEARS OR
OLDER RIGHT, YES, CORRECT
OKAY, BUT THE PAY WHEN WE RAN
EARLIER THAT'S FOR ALL OKAY
LAST, BUT CERTAINLRTY NORTT LERT
HERE.
AGO
FOR THIS WHO NOW
THERE'S A SPECIAL TECHNIQUE TO
THE LAMP ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET THAT
MOMENTUM MOMENTS AND LOTS OF
GRAY. NOT GOING HAVE SOME LIKE
DEATH TO TO
IT OH MY GOSH OKAY,
EVERYBODY HOW THEY CAN COME
VISIT YOU GUYS HERE IN TOWN
SQUARE YOUR BRAND LOCATION
FIND A NDSENSE OF MASS
DOT CODOM
E A
RESERVATIONS WALK-INS ARE
INCLUDED AS WELL TO YOU CAN
VISIT US AGAIN SINCE ITS MASS
DOT COM ALL COME THROUGH THE
TOWN SQUARE AND CAUSE STUFF,
OKAY AND ALSO YOU'RE NOT JUST
SMASHING.
>> YOU KNOW FOR FUN AGAIN.
THERE'S ALSO A PURPOSE TO IT
TALK ABOUT IT WITH A 100% SO
RIGHT AFTER WE SMASH
EVERYTHING PROCEEDS GO TO
NEVADA AS TO FINE HOMES FOR
OUR PETS IN NEED. I LOVE THAT
AND THIS IS A FOREVER HOME FOR
SOME FUN.
>> SOM